time
yeah so oh is the mic working okay great
so hi everyone i'm alexandra i'm a
second year graduate student at mit and
i'm going to tell you today about some
new results on single server private
information retrieval with subliner
america's time this is joint work with
my advisor henry corrigan gibbs in with
dima coven and it appeared at eurocrypt
earlier this year
so to begin i'm going to give you a very
quick refresher on private information
retrieval
so in the private information retrieval
problem we have a server that holds an
embed database
and we have a client that holds an index
i between one and n
what our client is going to want to do
is to privately read the ith database
bit
our client can do this if it interacts
with the server following a private
information retrieval or pir protocol
at the conclusion of this protocol the
client is going to learn exactly the if
the database bits while our server is
going to learn nothing about the index i
that the client is reading
in a wide array of prior work has shown
that if we use pir as a building block
we can build lots of very compelling
applications
for example we can build a system for
private media consumption where the
client fetches movies or news articles
from a server without revealing to the
server what it actually is interested in
or we can build systems for private
e-commerce privacy preserving
advertising and much more
so to date there's been lots of work on
making pir as practical of a primitive
as possible
in the setting where we have a client
that communicates with a single pir
server we know how to build pir with
relatively small communication costs
namely communication polylogarithmic in
the database size to n
unfortunately though as ellet already
explained pir requires high server-side
computation
and this is inherent
namely bymolisha and malkin proved a
lower bound that says that to answer
even a single pir query
the pir servers must do work that is
linear in the database size and
intuitively you can think of this as
follows if the pir server in answering a
query doesn't touch any one location of
the database then it learns that the
client probably isn't reading this
location and so this would leak
something about the query contents
so to avoid any leakage we need our
servers to do essentially a linear scan
over the entire database
fortunately though this is not the end
of the road because prior work has shown
that we can hope to amortize this linear
server time over many queries
in other words in the many query
settings we can build pir schemes where
the amortized server time per query is
sub-linear in the database size n
and so what i'd like to do now is to
survey the existing approaches to
building this pir with sub-linear time
the first such approach is what we call
batch pir
in the setting our client is going to
make a batch of queries at once and send
them all to the server
then our server is going to answer them
all together in time linear in the
database size and send all the answers
back to the client
so amortized over many queries the
server time per query is sub-linear in
the database size 10.
a second approach is what we call
offline online pir
in these schemes a client first
communicates with one server in an
offline phase and this offline phase is
going to require linear server time
but after this the client can make many
queries for which it communicates with
tool servers in an online phase that
requires only sub-linear server time
so again amortized over many queries the
server time per query is sub-linear in
the database size
a third approach is what we just heard
about which is what we call pir with
pre-processing
in these schemes our server is going to
run a one-time pre-processing step
during which it produces some encoding
of the database
and afterwards with this encoding it can
then answer queries from pir clients in
time sublinear in n
and finally a sort of trivial solution
to the pir problem is to just have the
client download the entire database
so the server pays a one-time linear
cost to ship the whole database to the
client the client stores its locally
stores it locally and then can just
answer all of its queries on its own
unfortunately each of these existing
approaches come with some limitations
that make them cumbersome to deploy in
practice
so batch pir requires the client to make
its queries non-adaptively rather than
slowly over time
offline online pir requires the client
to communicate with two non-colluding
servers which in practice requires
careful coordination between multiple
business entities
because the security now stems from the
fact that an adversary can't corrupt
both servers rather than from
cryptographic hardness
the known approaches to pir with
preprocessing in the single server
setting require the server to store some
encoding that consists of roughly n bits
for every client that it communicates
with
or they require virtual black box
obfuscation
and finally if the client downloads the
database then the client also needs to
store the whole database which is
impractical for large databases that are
gigabytes or even terabytes in size
so at this point the world of private
information retrieval is sort of in an
undesirable state
we just saw that there are compelling
applications but the known approaches to
single server pir aren't quite are more
expensive than we would like
yes
uh sorry what is that
that's the conversation
yeah exactly so it would be like the
permuted database and the secret key
setting and that's sort of random i
thought which means that
this
is like the secret conversion that each
client will need a separate box
so what we do in this work is we give
the first prs teams that jointly have a
number of properties that we care about
in practice
specifically our schemes are going to
let the client communicate with only a
single server
they're going to let the client make its
queries adaptively
they're going to have sublinear extra
storage of any kind specifically we're
going to have some sub-linear extra
storage on the client and no extra
storage on the server
and finally and most importantly our
server is going to run in sub-linear
amortized time
so as a quick preview of our results
we're going to give one scheme from ddh
where our server runs in time n to the 3
4 and our client has extra storage into
the three-fourths
and then we're going to show that from
the stronger assumption namely from fhe
we can do better
so we can have a server that runs in
time root n and a client that has extra
storage root n
in addition we also give some new lower
bounds on any many query pir scheme that
stores the database in unmodified form
and these lower bounds are going to
relate the server time and the client
storage
and they're going to show that our most
efficient fhe based scheme is in fact
optimal when it comes to this trade-off
yes
how many queries do you need to make
before the amortization kicks in yeah
that's a great question so i'm going to
go into that for both of these themes
but for the first one it's going to be n
to the one fourth and for the second one
it's going to be rooted okay
sorry the adaptive versus non-adaptive
so what's the
what's the event so is it that the
client can try to be adversarial or that
the server does not see all the queries
right away what's the what's the
question so i think of it really as a
difference in the application let's say
you're browsing wikipedia then you can
adaptively like click on one link from
one article to the next and to the next
so the difference is that you don't need
to make all of your queries up front but
instead you can make a first query and
then later decide what you want to query
next and then later on decide what you
want to pray next
what if i will make you random or if i
make where the next one is
no it's a correctness it's a
functionality thing
yeah it's client really kind of takes a
batch and does
depends even if i'm not being
adversaries it's still much harder yeah
not a great
question so what i'd like to do oh was
there a question are there secrets
involved
yes there are gonna there's gonna be
some secret client state
which is this gonna correspond to this
sub-linear extra storage on the client
so there is it's similar to this
um
yes
the database is
so in the rest of this talk i'd like to
do the following
first i'm going to give you some
background on the specific types of pr
schemes that we construct
and then i'm going to walk you through
our results so our new pir schemes with
sublinear amortized time and our new
lower bounds on many query pir
and finally i'd like to leave you with
some open questions in this area of
research
so to begin let's start with the
background
in this work our goal is to build pir
that lets the client make many adaptive
queries and the server run in sublinear
amortized time
so throughout this talk i'm going to use
q to denote a bound on the number of
adaptive queries that our client wants
to make
to meet this goal our approach is going
to be as follows
we're going to build pir schemes that
run in two phases
so first before our client knows which
indices it wants to query query it's
going to run a one-time offline phase
with the server and this is going to
require linear server time
after this offline phase for each of the
q adaptive queries that our client wants
to make it's going to run an online
phase with the server which is going to
require only sub-linear server time
so as you can tell if our number of
queries q is large enough namely if it's
at least n to the epsilon for some
constant epsilon then our server is
going to run in sublinear amortized time
per query
and at this point i just like to make
the distinction to related work clear
namely related work on offline online
pir in the single server setting only
supports one online query per offline
phase and so it cannot help to have this
sublinear amortized time
so now i'll show you how our schemes
look in a little more detail
first in an offline phase our client is
going to communicate with the server and
from this offline interaction it's going
to recover some hint about the database
contents
this hint is going to be sublinear in
the database size n and this offline
interaction is going to require linear
server time
after this at some point our client is
going to decide that it wants to read
some database index say index i1 and so
now it's again going to interact with
the server so send a query get back a
response and from this response in the
hint our client is going to be able to
recover the iwant database bit
even later our client is going to decide
that it wants to read the database again
say it cares about index i2 this time
and it can proceed exactly analogously
so run another online phase to recover
database bit i2
and this continues for queries
so you might wonder what happens if the
client wants to make a q plus one query
and if so our client can just run the
entire scheme again so run another
offline phase get a new hint and this
new hint is going to support few
additional queries and if it tries to
reuse the preprocessing for q plus one
you don't get security exactly that's
going to break our security guarantee
exactly
first so this is what the communication
pattern in our schemes looks like
and our requirements on these many query
prs themes are going to be as follows
first we care about correctness what
this means is that if we have an honest
client that is interacting with an
honest server
for any database held by the server and
for any queue adaptive indices queried
for by the client
our client will correctly recover the q
database bits that it's trying to read
with overwhelming probability
in addition we care about security and
more specifically malicious security
so what this means is that even if we
have a malicious server that does not
follow the protocol our server is going
to learn nothing about the queue
adaptive indices that the client is
reading
so for any two adaptive query sequences
i and i prime
our server's view is going to be
computationally indistinguishable
whether the client is making query
sequence i or making query sequence i
prime
and the way we achieve this malicious
security property is by ensuring that in
our schemes
structurally the client's queries are
always going to be independent of the
server's past answers
so this means that even by deviating
from the protocol a malicious server can
learn nothing more about the client's
queries than an honest but curious
server could
and finally given these two requirements
our goal is going to be to build pir
schemes that minimize the total cost
yes
i don't know what the performance of
that would be but
i don't see why not
yep
yeah so
you can't demonize the very first time
right by the lower bound but thereafter
i believe this should work yeah
uh okay yeah and so our what we're going
to want to do is minimize the
communication between the client and the
server
minimize the computation especially on
the server side and minimize the storage
which in our schemes is only on the
client side
great
so now we're ready to start looking at
some pir schemes and i'm going to start
by telling you what exactly it is that
we've proven this work
so the first thing that we prove is that
assumptions that imply linearly
homomorphic encryption are enough to
give us this sub-linear time pir
specifically under the decision
diffie-hellman quadratic residuocity
decision composite residuocity or
learning with errors assumptions
we can build a single server pir scheme
such that on database size n
and when our client makes at least n to
the one fourth adaptive queries
then our server is going to run an
amortized time into the three-fourths
our client is going to have storage
enter the three-fourths our server is
gonna is gonna have no extra storage
and our amortized client time and
amortized communication are also going
to be sublinear
and so this is a good point to note that
in these theorem statements and also
throughout the rest of this talk i'm
going to hide factors that are
logarithmic in the database size and
polynomials in the security parameter
great
so at this point we wondered whether we
could do better and we proved that from
stronger assumptions we can
namely assuming fully homomorphic
encryption we give a scheme that
improves the amortized over time to root
n and the client storage to root n if
our client makes at least root n
adaptive queries
and there's an asterisk here next to the
fhe because what we actually need is
something that we call gate by gate fhe
which just means that the fully
homomorphic evaluation routine is
efficient and standard fhe construction
satisfy this property
great
yes
in order to get the gain yes
uh yes yes so actually this is something
i wanted to point out right now which is
for theorem one the amortized server
time is optimal given the number of
ports namely by the linear server time
lower bound we cannot hope to have a
scheme that has server time better than
n2 reports if it only supports into the
one-fourth queries
and our trade-off is going to be
uh smooth for the second scheme so for
the number of queries q we're going to
get something like server time n over q
which is the best that we can do
yeah so i highlighted these numbers
because square root of n is where the
client storage and the server time
together are going to be the smallest
but yes it's going to for theorem 2 work
for any value
is that true is it true for theorem 1 as
well for theorem 1 it's not true no
right here in one we're going to need
another trade-off right
yeah the trade-off is different as well
yeah
all right
how much time
uh again amortizing the client offline
time and the client at one time so it's
going to be the client offline time
divided by the number of queries plus
the client all lifetimes
[Music]
what is that
and
i believe it's going to be group n but i
can get back to you
yeah yeah
yeah so our schemes are going to reduce
the server time at some expense for the
client and we're going to give some new
lower bounds that show that to some
extent this is inherent
right
yes so the second point i want to make
is we're going to give a new lower bound
that shows that in our second scheme
from fhc the tradeoff between the server
time and the client storage is going to
be optimal up to log n and poly lambda
factors
so what i'd like to do now is i'd like
to give you a sketch of a construction
that proves theorem 1.
so to prove theorem 1 at a very high
level we're going to proceed as follows
we're going to start with a pre-existing
result proved by my co-authors namely
that single query pir with sub-linear
online time exists
then what we're going to do is we're
going to give a new generic compiler
that takes as input a single query pr
scheme and outputs a mini query pr
scheme for queue adaptive queries
this compiler is going to apply ideas
from batch codes but crucially unlike
batch pir it's going to let the client
make its queries adaptively
and so what we get when we take the
pre-existing result and plug it into the
compiler is we get out a mini query pr
scheme with sublinear amortized time
which is exactly what we set out to
construct
so let's start by diving into the
pre-existing results
what my co-authors proved is that
assuming ddhqr dcr or lwe we can build a
single query pr scheme that looks as
follows
first in the offline phase our client is
again going to interact with the server
and it's going to recover a hint about
the database contents that has size into
the two-thirds
and this offline interaction is going to
require linear server time
then later on at some point our client
is going to decide that it wants to read
some database index i
and it's going to again interact with
the server to recover the i database bit
but this online phase is only going to
require into the two-thirds server
time so you might wonder why this scheme
doesn't already give us what we want and
the reason is that it's single query
the client can never reuse this hint to
make a second query and so even though
the online time is sublinear the total
per query time is still linear in the
database size
so our job is now going to be to compile
the scheme in a way to support q
adaptive queries
yes the hint is going to be secret for
the client only the client knows it and
uh
yes yeah you can interact with the
server as many times as you want the
server statements it only stores the end
bit database
you have to read it
uh
yes the server yeah so the server is
going to run in time and in the offline
phase because it's going to perform some
computation over the database and over
the client's
but in the online stages
please read their interests
uh you're you're asking whether the
server has already looked into the 2017
yeah so the in the online phase our
client is going to keep the hang for
itself and it's just going to make some
query to the server and from the
server's response in this hint it's
going to be able to recover the i1 or
the database 15.
yeah good question
so our idea is going to be to handle two
adaptive queries we're going to split
this database into q random chunks
specifically we're going to have our
client send a permutation over the
database indices to the server
our server is going to apply this
permutation to the database and then
it's going to chunk the database into
two chunks each of size and over q
and then we observe that by a balls and
bin style analysis when our client makes
q adaptive queries with overwhelming
probability
at most lambda distinct queries are
going to fall in any one chunk
in other words for our purposes it's
going to be sufficient to build a pir
scheme that lets the client adaptively
read from each chunk up to lambda times
so we're going to do exactly this as
follows
first in the offline phase we're going
to again have the client send a
permutation to the server the server is
going to permute and partition the
database into queue chunks each of size
and overkill
and then our client and our server are
going to run lambda offline phases of
the underlying single query pir scheme
on each of the two chunks
so our client is going to get back an
answer from the server and from this
it's going to recover lambda q hints
namely lambda hits about the contents of
each of the q chunks
later on our client is going to decide
that it wants to read some index i1 and
so what our client can do is first
figure out which chunk it is that i1
falls into
here i1 falls into the middle chunk and
so our client is going to select a hint
that matches this chunk
from this hint our client can build a
pir query exactly as in the underlying
prs scheme and it will send it to the
client to the server
our server then takes this pr query and
answers it with respect to each of the
queue database chunks
so our server sends q answers back to
the client
however our client knows that it's only
trying to read the middle chunk so our
client can take the middle answer and
the middle hint
and then recover the i want to database
bit exactly as in the underlying pr
scheme
finally our client is also going to
cache the ions database bit so if it
should ever want to query this index
again it can just use its locally cached
value and make a dummy query
and finally our client is going to throw
away the hint that it just used because
the underlying pr scheme is single query
so it can never reuse this hint for a
second query
now our client is happy it has recovered
the iwants database bits so the
permutation is uh it
is it could be a pseudo-random
permutation it's going to be a prp key
but then you are going to send the key
of the prp to the server yes yes and
this is going to be okay because the
randomness of the permutation is only
going to come up in our correctness
argument not in our security argument
so later on say our client wants to
query index i2
it can again proceed exactly analogously
and run another online phase with the
server so pick a hint send a query get
back to your responses and recover and
cache the i tooth database bit
sorry
so that we're only sending one
permutation so
uh
this is a good question i we didn't
think about this but i i can think about
it offline and get back to you so if the
clients like wants to make the same
index in a row
yeah yeah or it'll just cache the value
use it locally cache value and make a
dummy query so that the number of
queries doesn't leak
um
maybe i missed something but it's not
immediately obvious that the hint
doesn't reveal
the clear client's query doesn't reveal
the chunk that's yeah that's a great
question so this is something we address
in the paper by giving a slightly
different construction what i'm showing
you now actually abstracts this away
fully um but yeah so
in the paper what we do is we do this
construction with two servers and then
we compile it to to use only a single
server by using encryption for exactly
this three days and so this is going to
somehow this is going to complicate the
security arguments a little bit and
please see the paper for details
any other questions
so
you know from the hint you're only the
client is only going to look for a small
piece right can you so can you
recursively run sort of pir
you mean it's only going to use the
middle answer right yes yes okay we can
exactly do that too so we can use pir to
get only the middle answer and so this
is going to decrease the online
communication at the expense of
requiring the server to do some public
key operations in the online case
okay nice thanks maybe i'm missing
something uh can't the client
distinguish these two scenarios where in
one scenario all the queries are made
for the same chunk
scenario it's making quick difference
yes so the idea is our client is first
going to pick a permutation and then
it's going to slowly decide which
indices it wants to query and as long as
it doesn't decide which indices it wants
the query in a way that's correlated
with this permutation
then with overwhelming probability it's
going to be okay so this is exactly what
i want to do now is i want to give you
intuitive arguments for correctness and
security
so at a very
high level we argued before that for any
query sequence our client is not going
to read any one chunk more than lambda
times with overwhelming probability
and so again for any query sequence our
client is not going to run out of fresh
hints with overwhelming probability does
that make sense okay great
yes so security holds because
intuitively the underlying pr scheme is
secure so the server learns nothing
about which index the client is reading
within each chunk
and the client's query will not reveal
anything about which chunk it is reading
but as you pointed out there are some
details there that you can see in the
paper yes
which is bugging me which is
like the the servers responded to
like the service responses depending on
all the chunks yes so then it's not
clear that i can then query a trunk that
i haven't queried before and still be
secure right it could be that the
server's response to the first clear or
the servers
so each hint can be only used to make a
single query that's what the security
property of the underlying prx team sets
got it so with each hint our client is
still only making one query even though
our server is sending multiple answers
yeah
should we sign up because they use the
name to put a wrong account to generate
the quality
and then
yes exactly exactly perfect
great
and so this completes the construction
of the compiler and so you can see that
the cost of this scheme is dominated by
that of running the underlying pr steam
lambda q times each on a database of
size n over q so that's those that's the
sides of these chunks
and so what we can do now is we can pick
a value for q
we'll pick q to be n to the one-fourths
then we can look at the performance of
our input pir scheme think of running
the scheme lambda q times on database
size n over q
and this is exactly going to give us the
performance of our output pr scheme
namely we will see that we've just
constructed a scheme with hint size n to
the three fourths offline time n in
online time into the three fourths
and this scheme also supports n to the
one fourth queries
so the amortized per query server time
is entered the three-fourths
so we have indeed have a scheme with
sub-linear client storage and sub-linear
server amortized time which is exactly
what we want
uh sorry can you repeat the question can
you do
a bit more than
n to the one over four
so when you
yeah no for security you can't run the
scheme uh on more queries but what you
can do is you can just repeat the scheme
so when you run this twice it's not
going to change the amortized costs
yeah so you can run it for some a priori
unbounded number of queries by just
restarting the scheme from scratch and
all of the amortized costs are going to
stay the same but then you have to do a
multiple of 10 to the one part purpose
as well
uh
okay even if you do fewer if the
amortized cost will be the same i
believe okay great
so this completes the sketch of the
construction that i wanted to give you
for theorem one and you might wonder
whether we can prove theorem two in
exactly the same way
unfortunately the answer is no to prove
theorem two we give an entirely new pr
scheme from scratch and this is somewhat
more involved so i'm only going to leave
you with the high level ideas of how
this proof works
so at a high level to prove theorem two
we prove two claims
first we show that if the client has
some prior knowledge about the parities
of roughly q
random independent subsets of the
database each of size n over q
then our client can make q adaptive
queries each with online time and over q
and so again this is different from
prior work on single server offline
online pir because that only lets the
client make one adaptive query but now
we show that our client can in fact make
q adaptive queries
the second thing we do is we give a
boolean circuit for retrieving the
parities of roughly q subsets of the
database
each of size n over q
in roughly end gates
this boolean circuit makes use of
sorting networks and in our scheme we're
going to use it as follows
in the offline phase we're going to have
our server run this circuit under fhe
because our fat is gate-by-gate this is
going to require quasi-linear time
and because the server runs the scheme
under fhe it learns nothing about the
computation that it's performing
however at the end of this computation
our client is going to get exactly the
prior knowledge that it needs to buy
claim one make q adaptive queries each
with online time and over q
so in a little more detail this looks
as follows
in our offline phase our client is going
to sample roughly q subsets of the
database indices where each subset has
size n over q
and then our client is going to encrypt
all of the subsets and send them to the
server
our server is going to run our boolean
circuit for the batch retrieval of all
of the parities under fhe and send the
output back to the client and the client
decrypts and this is going to give it
exactly the parity of each of the
subsets
later on in the online phase our client
is going to decide that it wants to read
some index i1
and what our client can do is it can see
if it has some subset that contains i1
this check is going to pass with
overwhelming probability
and when it does our client is going to
flip a coin
and with good probability based on this
coin task our client is going to do two
things
first it's going to ask the surveyor for
the parity of the subset s with i1
removed
so since our client already knows the
parity of the subset s and then it gets
the parity of the subset s with i1
removed our client can exactly recover
the i want database bit
and after this our client is going to
have to discard the set s
intuitively our client can never reuse s
to make another query because then like
if it queried for index i2 it would send
s with i2 removed and this would leak
exactly the indices i1 and i2 that the
client queried
so our client is going to throw away s
but when it does so this is going to
change the distribution of the remaining
sets that the client is holding
specifically our client just picked a
set that contained i1 and then threw it
away and so at this point our client is
going to refresh its distribution of
subsets to ensure that it remains random
and specifically to do so it's going to
take i1 and insert it into some other
random set
right and so if either of these two
failure events occurs namely if the
client doesn't have a set s that
contains i1 or if the coin toss says
that the client shouldn't execute this
branch then our client is just going to
ask the server for the parity of a
random subset that with some
predetermined probability is going to
contain i1
great
so what we can do now is we can repeat
this whole scheme lambda times
then we're going to get that our
correctness holds with overwhelming
probability because with overwhelming
probability in at least one of these
lambda trials our client is going to
recover the iowans database bit
and intuitively our security is going to
hold because in the offline phase the
server learns nothing about the contents
of the sets since they're encrypted and
so in the online phase the client's
queries are just going to look like
completely random subsets of the
database
and finally the performance of the
scheme is going to be as follows
our client storage is going to
correspond to these roughly q parities
of subsets so it's going to be on the
order of qubits
our server's offline time is going to be
on the order of n because our server is
going to run this batch parity retrieval
circuit
and in the online phase our server is
only going to get a set of size n over q
minus one and it's going to retrieve its
parity so the online time is going to be
n over q
and so finally when we take q to be root
n we're indeed going to get a scheme
where our client makes root and adaptive
queries with client storage root n and
amortized server time root n
great
so this completes what i wanted to tell
you about theorem 2 and i just want to
leave you with some
very quick thoughts about our new lower
bounds
so
the first lower bound that we prove in
this paper is a lower bound on pir
schemes where the client makes its
queries adaptively
specifically we prove that for any
single server pir scheme where the
client makes its queries adaptively
the server stores the endbit database in
its original form
the client stores s bits between queries
and the server runs in amortized time t
it must hold that the product of the
client storage s and the server time t
is at least n
in other words this lower bound rules
out any pr schemes with both small
client storage and small server time
then we wondered whether we could do
better if the client makes its queries
non-adaptively and so we proved a second
lower bound in this setting
specifically we showed that if the ser
the client can make a batch of q
non-adaptive queries at once
then it must be that either
the product of the client storage s in
the server time t is at least n
or the product of the batch size q in
the server time t is at least n yes
yes
right yeah so we only have a one-sided
privacy property in this work so the
server should not learn which index the
client is
trying to read but the client can read
it learn as much of the databases and
not but specifically you can just
looking at your skills yep exactly
great
so just to put these lower bounds in the
bigger picture
what our first lower bound here is doing
is it's generalizing the linear server
time lower bound to include some fine
storage and our second lower bound
additionally includes uh some batch
queries
and at this point i'd also like to
mention some other related work on lower
bounds on pir with pre-processing
so in the pr with pre-processing our
server is going to store b extra bits
but our client is going to have no
storage so s is zero in this case
and what bimo and shy and mal can prove
is that with any number of pir servers
the product of the server storage b in
the server time t has to be at least n
and recently persiano and yale
strengthened this bound in the single
server setting to show that if b is
large enough then actually the product
of the server storage b and the server
time t has to be at least and log in
great and so now i just want to leave
you with the high level takeaways from
these bounds
but first of all theorem three here
shows that our fhe based construction is
optimal when it comes to the trade-off
between the server time and the client
storage
what theorem 4 shows is that if the
client storage is small namely if s is
smaller than the batch size q
then existing batch pir has the optimal
server time
however if the client storage is large
enough namely if it's at least the batch
size queue
then our new adaptive pir has the
optimal server time
so in a sense with enough client storage
we've shown that query adaptivity in pir
can come for free
and just quickly for those of you who
are interested we proved theorem 2 with
a reduction to single query pir and we
proved theorem 4 with an
incompressibility argument so
specifically we showed that any pr
scheme that defies this lower bound
could be used to build a better than
possible compression algorithm great
and so now i'm just going to briefly
leave you with some open questions
what we saw in this talk is that
adaptive single server pir with
sublinear server time in sublinear
storage is theoretically feasible
unfortunately our schemes are not quite
concretely efficient enough for use in
practice
specifically there are a few lambda and
login factors that i hid throughout this
talk and this sort of thing accumulates
very quickly in practice
this means that there's still a lot of
work left to be done to push pr closer
to practice and there's already been
some follow-up work that improves the
communication of our fhe-based scheme to
of1
other exciting open questions are
whether we can construct optimal schemes
so schemes that match our lower bounds
from assumptions weaker than fhe
and whether we can somehow circumvent
our lower bounds by having the server
store the database in encoded form
great
so i'd like to thank you for your
attention and refer you to the paper for
many more details on everything i told
you about and i'm happy to take any
questions
[Applause]
maybe one more question is any
can you combine these schemes with uh
snatching if you have like a server
receiving for a bunch of clients like
each client going sequentially if you
have a bunch of clients in parallel ah
yeah so you're asking whether we can get
some amortized savings if we have
queries from different clients rather
than queries from the same time well i
mean same clients still doing a bunch of
queries in sequence and follow the same
basic pattern but do that in parallel
across a bunch of clients yeah so our
server is stateless in this case so it
can
communicate with as many clients as we'd
like and
run this scheme independently for each
client
i mean some of the badges
yeah so we can amortize only within a
single client we don't know how to
amortize if we have a bunch of clients
that make only one query yeah so there's
some related work uh that
uh
achieves this but like intuitively like
you can think of it as if you have a pr
scheme where what the server is doing is
it's computing a matrix vector product
then if a bunch of clients in their
queries at once you can compute a matrix
matrix product and you can speed this up
with fast matrix multiplication and then
you get sub linear amortized time yeah
this doesn't apply to our work okay i'm
wondering if you can combine that like
when you have a sort of two-dimensional
like at each moment you've got a bunch
of clients and each client is doing what
you're talking about or a bunch of a
series of queries then can you do like
amortize horizontally and vertically
yeah not that we know with our speeds
that's a great direction for future work
as well
okay i think that's it
[Music]